[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundola
Gause und Marietta
Slomka guten Abend falls Sie noch keinen
Plan für Silvester haben geschweige denn
gute Vorsätze fürs neue Jahr macht
nichts die Bundesregierung weiß noch
nicht mal wie sie ihren Haushalt fürs
neue Jahr aufstellt und einige
Koalitionäre finden dass es damit selbst
jetzt am 4.12 noch gar nicht so alt die
FDP jedenfalls sagt lieber gründlich als
vorschnell andere in der Koalition
scheinen diese neue deutsche
Gelassenheit noch nicht ganz inhallert
zu haben SPD und Grüne wollen lieber bis
übermorgen klar Schiff haben denn dann
ist
Kabinettssitzung so oder so ist die
Debatte wo die fehlenden Milliarden
herkommen sollen in vollem Gange aktuell
im Mittelpunkt das Bürgergeld Andreas
hert und Lars bunsack
berichten eine Kiste Obst und Gemüse ein
paar Eier Wurst und Käse 1 € bezahlen
Bedürftige bei der Tafel eine Woche muss
das reichen nicht nur hier in Berlin
registrieren Sie einen stetig wachsenden
anrang immer mehr Menschen sind auf die
Hilfe angewiesen wir haben hier eine
relativ große Ausgabestelle wir
versorgen im Monat 360 Haushalte das war
früher deutlich anders da waren wir
vielleicht bei 250 Haushalten viele
ältere Rentner aber in erster Linie
eigentlich bürgergeldempfänger seit dem
Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts streitet
die Ampel darüber wie man die 17
Milliarden Euro die laut Finanzminister
im Haushalt des nächsten Jahres fehlen
einsparen kann die FDP bringt das
Bürgergeld ins Spiel und will die auch
von ihr gesetzlich verabschiedete
erhöhung zum 1 Januar wieder deutlich
absenken zu dem Zeitpunkt als die
Steigerung ja letztendlich finalisiert
wurde ist hat man eine Inflationsrate
von 9,9% prognostiziert wir haben heute
eine andere Entwicklung wir haben heute
jetzt stand jetzt sind wir bei etwa 3%
also dort wo die Inflation im Grunde
genommen seit August 2021 nicht mehr war
12% machen rund 3,4 Milliarden Euro für
die Liberalen also genug Spielraum für
Einsparungen im Sozialhaushalt diese
Idee stößt nicht nur bei den
Koalitionspartnern auf scharfe Kritik
die Sozialverbände verweisen auf das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das mehrfach
eine klare Linie beim Existenzminimum
gesetzt hat was für mich immer
schockierend und erschütternd ist dass
auf Kosten der ärmsten hier Politik
gemacht wird und wirklich manche eben
nicht vor dem Populismus zurückschrecken
immer bei den Ärmsten sparen zu wollen
und bei allen anderen die vielleicht
eher ihrer Wählerklientel zuzusprechen S
sind eben nicht den Rotstift me ansetzen
noch weiter als die FDP geht die Union
sie lehnt nicht nur die Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes ab sondern will die
Sozialleistung als Ganzes kippen wir
werden das Bürgergeld in dieser Form
wieder abschaffen allein der Begriff
Bürgergeld suggeriert dass es allen
zusteht ist totaler Quatsch das müssen
diejenigen bekommen die wirklich
hilfebedürftig sind und alle anderen die
Arbeiten können die müssen auch eine
Arbeit nachgehen das ist so in einem
Sozialstaat und das wird auch den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt stärken
im Arbeitsministerium sehen Sie das
Bürgergeld nicht als Verhandlungsmasse
es werde keine Kürzungen geben zumal
geltende Gesetze eingehalten werden
müssen das ist nicht nur ein Gebot der
moralischen Vernunft sondern auch ein
Gebot unserer Verfassung es ist deshalb
nicht verantwortlich diesen Menschen die
Anpassung zu verweigern wie das einige
konservative Politiker in Deutschland
fordern Deutschland ist ein sozialer
rechtst ST und deutschland ist ein Land
in dem Solidarität geboten ist die
bürgergelderhöhung wird wohl wie geplant
kommen hier bei der Tafel wissen sie
auch das reicht für viele nicht und so
werden Sie auch nächste Woche
wiederkommen eine Kiste 1
€ dann wollen wir auf das Thema
Bürgergeld noch einen ganz nüchtern
juristischen Blick werfen mit einem
Experten für Verfassungsrecht und
Staatsfinanzen mit Professor Joachim
Wand Professor für öffentliches Recht an
der Universität für Verwaltungs
Wissenschaften in Speier guten Abend
Herr Professor
wiand guten Abend Frau slonker wir haben
es eben gehört Herr Hall sagte na ja
also das ist eigentlich durch
Verfassungsgericht festgelegt und da
gibt's festgelegte Verfahren dafür wie
das Bürgergeld erhöht wird das klingt
ein bisschen so als hätte die Politik da
quasi kaum Einfluss
drauf die Politik hat wenig Einfluss
darauf das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat tatsächlich
sehr strikte Vorgaben für die Sicherung
des Existenzminimums gemacht das muss
zeitnah erfolgen das muss transparent
sein man muss das nachvollziehen können
und das alles wird abgeleitet aus der
Garantie der Menschenwürde die jedem
garantiert in Deutschland dass er nicht
hungern muss nicht frieren muss und ein
Dach über dem Kopf hat sagt die Union
und auch auch Teile der FDP ja
Menschenwürde schon aber die
Inflationsrate die ist ja jetzt
überhaupt nicht mehr so hoch wir haben
es gerade im Beitrag ja auch gehört und
dann braucht eine so hohe Erhöhung für
das Bürgergeld auch nicht
sein man kann darüber streiten man kann
nie einen Betrag in Cent und Euro
praktisch aus dem Grundgesetz ableiten
aber viel Spielraum besteht da nicht
weil die Inflation im letzten Jahr schon
weit fortgeschritten war bevor man das
Bürgergeld angepasst hat und in diesem
Jahr wird da ein gewisser nachhohleffekt
nachvollzogen also Kleinigkeiten könnte
man sicher von verfassungswegen ändern
aber grundsätzlich eiget sich das
Bürgergeld aufgrund der Vorgaben der
Verfassung und des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts kaum dazu viel
Geld einzusparen zumal wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe ja die
Inflationsrate auch noch mal anders
gewichtet wird das bezieht sich nicht
nur auf die allgemeine
Inflationsrate nein das ist
praktisch ausgerichtet auf dem Bedarf
den jemand hat der wenig Geld hat der
muss viel Geld für Lebensmittel ausgeben
was teuer geworden ist für Strom der
teurer geworden ist
das ist eine besondere Berechnung die
aber gerade die Bedürfnislage Treffen
soll der Menschen um deren
Existenzminimum es hier geht sagten sie
gerade da ist nicht viel Spielraum aber
klar auf Heller und ffennig oder centen
Euro ist das nicht festgelegt wenn man
jetzt noch was ändern wollte für den
Haushalt 24 also fürs nächste Jahr und
sagen bürgergelderhöhung da müssen wir
jetzt ein paar Cent oder ein paar Euro
im Monat runternehmen ginge das
überhaupt noch jetzt mal rein juristisch
gefragt juristisch wäre das sehr schwer
äh bis zum 1 Januar ist das nicht mehr
vorstellbar man könnte frühestens
vielleicht zum 1 April vielleicht auch
erst zum 1 Juno eine neu Regelung
einführen und die hätte erheblichen
Verwaltungsaufwand weil man dann
möglicherweise rückwirkend etwas äh
streichen oder zahlen müsste also meines
Erachtens ist realistisch eigentlich er
ist eine Änderung für
2025 in dem begrenzten Rahmen den die
Verfassung lässt und wenn jetzt wie z.B
Markus Söder fordert eine
Generalüberholung des ganzen
bürgergeldsystems angestrebt werden
würde müsste man dann auch im Prinzip
die Regelsätze die Berechnungsgrundlagen
das grundsätzlich ändern
äh wenn man eine Generalüberholung will
kann man natürlich versuchen einen etwas
anderen Ansatz zu wählen aber man kommt
nicht an den Grundtatsachen vorbei das
Existenzminimum ist gesichert man muss
das realistisch berechnen und da gibt es
politisch wenig Spielraum also ein ganz
anderes System ist eigentlich schwer
vorstellbar gibt's den den anderen
Bereichen der Sozialetat ist ja sehr
sehr groß ich glaube über 170 fast 180
Milliarden da gbt's da andere Bereiche
wo man eher wenn man jetzt Lücken
stopfen will oder Geld frei machen will
juristisch gesehen ran
kann juristisch gesehen könnte man ran
an den Bundeszuschuss zur
Rentenversicherung da gibt es deut
weniger Vorgaben das ist ein Stück weit
im politischen Ermessen des Gesetzgebers
aber es betrifft natürlich mehr als 20
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner und
das ist für die Politik eine heikle
Hürde man will nicht seine Wählerinnen
und Wähler vergraulen
beim Bürgergeld sind es deutlich weniger
Menschen die betroffen sind zumal auch
dort in dem Bereich die Wahlbeteiligung
niedriger ist als bei den retnern Herr
Professor wiand danke Ihnen für diese
Einschätzungen gerne
und zwischen den ganzen
koalitionsdebatten hat der Bundeskanzler
auch noch Staatsgäste zu betreuen was
auch nicht immer leicht ist Brasiliens
Präsident Lula etwa über dessen Wahlsieg
hatten sich die deutschen
Sozialdemokraten eigentlich sehr gefreut
aber seit seinem Amtsantritt hat die
Begeisterung etwas abgenommen zur
Ukraine und Israel vertritt Lula ganz
andere Ansichten mit Staaten wie
Russland und Iran hat er keine
Berührungsängste und china ist für ihn
mindestens so wichtig wie Europa bei
seinem Besuch in Berlin geht es vor
allem um das große südamerikanisch
europäische
Freihandelsabkommen über das seit über
20 Jahren verhandelt wird da wird viel
von Scholz und Lula abhängen berichtet
Andreas
Künast als der deutsche Präsident noch
lange nicht Präsident war sondern Leiter
der Staatskanzlei in Hannover und als
der brasilianische Präsident noch lange
nicht nicht Präsident war sondern ein
rebellischer Abgeordneter der sich
weigerte eine Krawatte zu tragen
begannen Europa und Südamerika über ein
Freihandelsabkommen nachzudenken an
diesem Freitag gleich nach seiner
Rückkehr aus Deutschland will Lula da
Silva es abschließen es wäre ein
historischer Deal beinah ein Vermächtnis
heiß ersehn heiß bekämpft fast drei
Jahrzehnte lang aber es sieht nicht gut
aus ich werde nicht solange ich nicht
mit allen Präsidenten gesprochen habe
und dann werden wir sehen auch
Deutschland bemüht sich um das merkosur
Abkommen aber vor allem bemüht sich
Deutschland um Lula der Bundespräsident
trifft Lula die Bundesratspräsidentin
trifft Lula der Bundeskanzler trifft
Lula es gibt so viele und so gravierende
Differenzen zwischen Brasilien und
Deutschland dass das Freihandelsabkommen
im besten Fall nicht nur der Wirtschaft
sondern auch der Politik helfen würde
eine Annäherung auf dieser Ebene die
Brasilien und andere Länder des globalen
Südens mit Europa zusammenbringt wäre
gut vielleicht nicht gleich für die
Neuordnung der Welt aber für die
Verteidigung von Menschenrechten und
Demokratie Olaf Scholz war Vorsitzender
des SPD Kreisverbands Altona als die
ersten Gespräche über den Abbau von
Zöllen und Barrieren begannen die in das
Freihandelsabkommen merkosur münden
sollen in eine Freihandels
für 700 Millionen Menschen aber
Argentinien und Frankreich der neue
Präsident m und der nicht mehr neue
Präsident macron sagen vier Tage vor
Abschluss nein macron unter anderem um
Frankreichs Landwirtschaft zu
schützen wir werden versuchen noch
einige Kleinigkeiten im Abkommenstext zu
korrigieren vielleicht gelingt es Olaf
ma zu
überugenit ich alle
bet
Pragmatismus und größtmögliche
Kompromissbereitschaft damit wir das
jetzt endlich finalisieren können
Brasiliens Präsident ist mit fast all
seinen Ministern nach Berlin gekommen
auch Lula bemüht sich um Deutschland
aber grundlegende Unterschiede bleiben
in den zwei großen Kriegen dieser Zeit
fordert der Präsident die Ukraine und
Israel zu Verhandlungen auf während der
Kanzler das Recht betont sich zu
verteidigen unser Standpunkt ist dass
das eben bedeutet dass dieser dass
Israel auch das Recht haben muss die
Hamas zu besiegen und daran zu hindern
solche Terrortaten weiter
durchzuführen man kann nur über Frieden
diskutieren wenn man verhandelt das ist
die Rolle der Vereinten Nationen und die
erfüllt sie nicht dann machen sich Lula
und Scholz an den Versuch das merkosur
Abkommen zu retten es sieht nicht gut
aus es braucht vielleicht noch ein paar
politikergenerationen
und jetzt geht's bei Gundula weiter
zunächst mit dem Krieg im Nahen Osten
israel hat seine massiven Militärschläge
und den Einsatz von Bodentruppen auf den
ganzen Gazastreifen ausgeweitet ziel
bleibe die Zerstörung der Hamas betonte
erneut ein
Armeesprecher zugleich wächst das Leid
der Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen
Militäroperationen in chanjunis und in
Raffa waren durch massive Luftangriffe
vor bereitet worden das israelische
Militär hatte die Bevölkerung über das
Internet und Flugzettel zur Flucht in
den Süden
aufgerufen die russischen Streitkräfte
verstärken bei eisigen Temperaturen ihre
Angriffe an der gesamten Front im Süden
der Ukraine vor allem auf
afdiivka das ukrainische Militär rechnet
außerdem mit neuen massiven Schlägen
gegen das Stromnetz den russischen Krieg
gegen die Energie Versorgung hat auf der
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai ein
US-Vertreter angeprangert internationale
Forscher beschrieben zudem die Menge
klimaschädlicher Treibhausgase durch
Russlands Krieg und forderten Moskau
müsse dafür
zahlen unterdessen droht der Ukraine die
finanzielle und militärische
Unterstützung der USA wegzubrechen die
vom US-Kongress bewilligten Mittel für
Kiev laufen zum Jahresende aus
eindringlich hat die US-Regierung den
Kongress zur Freigabe weiterer Hilfen
für die Ukraine aufgefordert während die
russische Rüstungsindustrie ihre
Produktion hoch fährt verzeichnen die
100 größten Rüstungskonzerne der Welt
trotz des ukrainekrieges für 2022
weniger Einnahmen
umgerechnet
543 Milliarden Euro 3,5% wenig als im
Vorjahr zurückzuführen auf die großen
US-amerikanischen Konzerne die die
steigende Nachfrage nicht bedienen
konnten laut Friedensforschungsinstitut
Sipri ist wegen vieler Aufträge aber mit
höheren Einnahmen zu rechnen im Norden
Tansanias ist die Zahl der Todesopfer
durch Erdrutsche nach starken
Regenfällen auf mindestens 68 gestiegen
über 100 Menschen wurden verletzt
besonders betroffen die stad katesch
Fahrzeuge wurden weggespült Gebäude zum
Einsturz gebracht nach einer Dürre
Periode gibt es in Ostafrika seit Wochen
starke Regenfälle und Überschwemmungen
fachleute sehen einen Zusammenhang mit
dem Wetterphänomen el
ninu zur Weltklimakonferenz kann
Wirtschaftsminister habbeg ja nicht
reisen sondern muss ich daheim um
Haushalt und Koalitionsklima kümmern
immerhin hatte der Bundeskanzler noch
eine schnelle Visite zur Konferenz in
Dubai geschafft auch um den sogenannten
klimaclub weiter voranzutreiben eine
Idee die maßgeblich von Deutschland
initiiert wurde der Club ist sozusagen
eine Koalition der Willigen die bereit
sind beim Klimaschutz enger
zusammenzuarbeiten den Vorsitz teilt
sich Deutschland mit Chile warum
ausgerechnet Chile das südamerikanische
Land hat sich eine große Energiewende
vorgenommen und könnte in Zukunft als
Produzent grünen Wasserstoffs ein
wichtiger Handelspartner für Europa
werden Hintergrunde dazu von Christop
Röcker es ist die Kraft der 10000 Sonnen
10600 Spiegel lenken die Strahlen auf
die Spitze des Turms im serod dominador
gelegen in der atakama Wüste
Chiles Spiegel statt Solarzellen die mit
ihrem gebündelten Licht geschmolzenes
Salz erhitzen das durch die Turmspitze
gepumpt wird und dort Temperaturen von
mehr als 500° cel erreicht das Besondere
das Salz kann diese Hitze speichern und
so kontinuierlich über die Turbinen am
Fuß des sonnenturms Strom erzeugen
selbst wenn die Sonne nicht
scheint dies ist eine Technologie mit
der wir die Energie über eine lange Zeit
speichern
können wir können Sie 24 Stunden 7 Tage
in der Woche abrufen mit dieser Technik
können wir also den Kampf aufnehmen
gegen die fossilen Brennstoffe vor allem
gegen Gas und Kohle
wie Gas und Kohle ist flüssiges Salz
eine stetige kontrollierbare
Energiequelle im Labor der Universität
von Antofagasta tüfteln die Forscher
weiter am optimalen Salzgemisch um die
Speicherkapazität noch zu verbessern
500° heißes flüssiges Salz dampft nicht
es hält die Energie eine hitzebatterie
die sich jahrzehnteelang wieder
verwenden lässt und rund um die Uhr
grüne Energieproduktion ermöglicht das
ruft auch die EU auf den Plan denn so
wäre endlich die Produktion von grünem
Wasserstoff in großen Mengen möglich
hoffen
sie 2030 wollen wir 10 Millionen Tonnen
grünen Wasserstoff in die EU importieren
so viiel ist bisher noch gar nicht auf
dem Weltmarkt verfügbar grüne Energie
könnte bisher wirtschaftlich kaum
nutzbare Regionen in goldgrobben
verwandeln globale Kräfteverhältnisse
verschieben dieser unscheinbare Anhänger
soll Chile dabei helfen ist die weltweit
einzige mobile
wasserstofffabrik mit ihr fahren Sie
durch die Wüste um so die besten
Standorte für die großen Fabriken zu
ermitteln auf deren Bau die
energiehungrigen Europäer ihre
Hoffnungen
setzen bisher allerdings kommt auch in
Chile ein Großteil des Stroms aus
Kohlekraftwerken die aber sollen künftig
ohne Kohle funktionieren in angamos
nördlich von antopagasta bauen Sie das
erste Kraftwerk um auf
salzbetrieb Sonnenenergie wird das Salz
tagsüber Aufheizen erklärt der Chef der
Umbau sei nichts Geringeres als eine
Revolution mit globalen
Auswirkungen sollte das funktionieren
hat es ein riesiges Zukunftspotenzial
rein technisch gesehen kann jedes
thermoelektrische Kraftwerk in ein
salzkraftwerk umgewandelt
werden noch gibt es technische Fragen zu
klären auch die Stromnetze müssen
ausgebaut werden aber die Umwandlung ist
beschlossene Sache und auch in Europa
wird an der Technik geforscht selbst
wenn dort die Sonne nicht so intensiv
scheint wie in Chile könnte das flüssige
Salz Schwankungen natürlicher
Energiequellen ausgleichen und den
Einsatz fossiler Energie zumindest
reduzieren anlässlich der
Weltklimakonferenz finden Sie in unserer
ZDF heute App noch viele zusätzliche
Informationen und auch einen
interaktiven
klimaglobus dort können Sie z.B sehen
wie sich die Küstengebiete verändern
wenn das Eis an den Polen weiter schmilt
oder auf welchen Kontinenten Menschen
und Tiere besonders stark unter den
Folgen des Klimawandels leiden und vom
Klima kommen wir jetzt zum
wettergundela starke Schneefälle vor
allem im Süden Deutschlands haben zu
weiteren Einschränkungen auf Straßen und
im Bahnverkehr geführt die Deutsche Bahn
erwartet bis zur Wochenmitte
wetterbedingte Verzögerungen wegen der
Schneemassen sind tausende Mitarbeiter
in winterdiensteinsetzen auf vielen
verschneiten Straßen kam es zu Unfällen
der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt vieler
Orts vor Glatteis und Eisregen der
Münchner Flughafen stellt deswegen den
Betrieb morgen früh von 6 bis 12 Uhr
ein die Zahl der Firmenpleiten ist in
diesem Jahr deutlich um mehr als 23%
gestiegen und die
Wirtschaftsauskunft taii Kreditreform
rechnet mit weiter steigenden Zahlen
Frank betetmann an der Börse was kommt
da auf die deutsche Wirtschaft zu ja die
Aussichten sind düster die Entwicklung
überrascht allerdings nicht Corona hohe
Energiepreise steigende Zinsen immer
mehr Firmen unter ihnen überwiegend
kleine Betriebe mit weniger als zehn
Mitarbeitern brechen unter der
Dauerbelastung der letzten Jahre
zusammen können Ihre Rechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen besonders betroffen die
Baubranche aber auch Handelshäuser hier
sehr viele Modehändler oder im
Gesundheitswesen Pflegedienste und
Krankenhäuser mit großen Problemen die
von Kreditreform für dieses Jahr auf
Basis von Daten geschätzten über 18.000
Firmenpleiten viel aber kein Höchststand
den gab es bislang im Jahr 2003 mit über
39 000 Insolvenzen im Jahresdurchschnitt
sind es knapp
26200 also kein pleiterekord eine Pleite
Welle wie sie es schon mal gab sinden
die Experten auf Deutschland auch nicht
zurollen besorgniserregend ist das Ganze
jedoch allemal ja das konjunkturelle
Umfeld bleibt schwierig wo liegen denn
die Hauptbelastungen na es trifft die
Unternehmen auf breiter Front die
Kaufzurückhaltung der Kunden die
einbrechenden Verkaufszahlen erst heute
wurden wieder schwache Exportzahlen
gemeldet und auf der anderen Seite eben
Betriebe die mit den steigenden Kosten
nicht mehr klar kommen und ihre Probleme
bereits seit mehreren Jahren vor sich
herchieben Frank betmann vielen Dank für
die
Einschätzung zum Sport bei der Handball
WM der Frauen in dänemark hat das
dhbteam gerade eben den Gruppensieg in
der Vorrunde ja ich sehe gerade wie
hätten noch eine Meldung zu Trier in der
Sendung gehabt da bitte ich um
Verzeihung dieses Urteil zur Amokfahrt
in Trier wurde aufgehoben muss in Teilen
neu aufgerollt werden der
Bundesgerichtshof hat das mordurteil des
Trierer Landgerichts wegen Rechtsfehlern
überwiegend aufgehoben und damit gab der
BGH der der Revision des Angeklagten
statt die Schuldunfähigkeit des
schizophrenen Mannes sei in dem Urteil
nicht rechtsfehlerfrei begründet worden
bei der Amokfahrt hatte der Verurteilte
mit seinem Auto Passanten in der Trierer
Fußgängerzone gezielt angefahren sechs
Menschen
starben so jetzt aber zum Sport und
bitte um Entschuldigung bei der Handball
WM der Frauen in Dänemark hat das
dhbteam also gerade eben den Gruppensieg
in der Vorrunde erzielt mit einem
33:17 Sieg gegen Polen beide Teams waren
schon für die Hauptrunde qualifiziert
die deutsche Mannschaft hatte bereits
gegen Japan und Iran
gewonnen die frisch gebackenen U-17
Fußballweltmeister sind nach ihrem
Triumph in Indonesien bei der Rückkehr
begeistert empfangen worden im
Frankfurter Römer trug sich das Team von
Trainer Christian Wück ins Goldene Buch
der Stadt ein der DFB hofft dass der U17
Erfolg auch auf die heimem im nächsten
Jahr
ausstrahlt DFB Präsident Neuendorf lobte
die Mentalität der jungen Mannschaft und
sprach von einem
Wintermärchen der Sport ist auch so ein
Bereich wo ohne ehrenamtliche praktisch
gar nichts geht jedenfalls nicht im
breitenport wer trainiert in tausenden
kleinen Fußballvereinen die
Jugendmannschaften wer kümmert sich um
Sommerfest oder übernimmt das Amt des
Schatzmeisters das gilt erst recht für
den Sozialbereich und auch für die
Lokalpolitik Kommunalpolitik würde es
praktisch kaum mehr geben wenn sich
nicht immer wieder Menschen finden die
dafür Teile ihrer Freizeit und auch
Teile ihres Nervenkostüms Opfern
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat heute 19
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für ihr Ehrenamt
ausgezeichnet darunter einen jungen Mann
der bereits mit un Jahren anfing sich zu
engagieren Markus wohsiffer stellt ihn
vor während Colin Rimbach derzeit über
seinen Büchern brütet sich auf das
Abitur vorbereitet schauen ihm viele
Augen über die Schulter diese endchen
sind zum Symbol seines außergewöhnlichen
Engagements geworden mit dem Verkauf der
Enten hat der 19-Jährige über 111 000 €
gesammelt alles für den guten Zweck ich
würde sagen dass mein Antrieb ein
Antrieb ist ja noch ganz viele andere
Ehrenamtler in sich tragen und ich
glaube tatsächlich auch jeder Mensch das
Gefühl aus einer Situation heraus in der
es einem selbst ziemlich gut geht aber
man trotzdem die Ungerechtigkeiten in
der Welt sieht und diese auch als solche
erkennt dann aus dieser Situation heraus
anderen helfen zu wollen und diese
Ungerechtigkeiten zu
bekämpfen im Alter von 9 Jahren beginnt
die Aktion
entenfreund Colin will etwas Gutes tun
er schafft es einige Hersteller zu
überzeugen ihm badeändchen zu überlassen
seitdem steht er in Supermärkten und
Innenstädten unermütlich um für den
deutschen Kinder PZ Verein zusammen
dessen Vorstand tief beeindruckt von
Collins jahrelangem Engagement also wenn
ein neunjähriger Junge sich zum Thema
Kinder und jugendhospizarbeit Gedanken
macht und dann auch noch selber in
Aktion tritt und so viel Öffentlichkeit
und so viel Spenden hereinholt das ist
sehr außergewöhnlich also das haben wir
so in dieser Form sehr sehr
selten die Auszeichnung des
Bundespräsidenten heute eine große Ehre
für
Colin über die große Hoffnung dass meine
Arbeit und die Arbeit all jener die
heute hier ausgezeichnet wurden weitere
Menschen in ganz Deutschland dazu
inspirieren wird auch ehrenamtlich aktiv
zu werden doch zur Realität gehört auch
dass Colin in all den Jahren immer
wieder beleidigt wurde manche
beschimpften ihn gar als Umweltsünder
weil die änchen aus Plastik sind
mangelnder Respekt vor dem Ehrenamt
keine Seltenheit freiwillige feuerwren
klagen darüber dass sie im Einsatz
Gewalt erfahren verbal und körperlich
oder in den Tafeln viele Freiwillige
haben das Gefühl dass sich die Politik
auf ihnen ausruhe die Ehrenamtler werden
es schon richten wenn sich dieses Gefühl
ausbreitet in einer Gesellschaft sei das
höchst problematisch warnen
ehrenamtsforscher
ehrenamtliches Engagement ist der Kit
der unsere Gesellschaft zusammenhält und
wenn das wegfällt dann ist das natürlich
fatal weil diese vertrauensvollen
Beziehungen zwischen Menschen die im
ehrenamtlichen Engagement Entstehen
dieser Austausch von verschiedenen
Perspektiven und Erfahrungen dann
wegfällt dann geht wie die Wissenschaft
es nennt Kapital verloren oder anders
formuliert es geht weniger menschlich zu
trotz mancher Anfeindungen colin hat
immer weitergemacht 10 Jahre lang
mittlerweile musste er die Aktion
beenden seines Abiturs wegen was danach
kommt offen am liebsten träumt Colin
will er Schriftsteller werden die Welt
mit seinen Worten verändern mit seinen
Taten hat er bereits viel
bewirkt morgen ist internationaler Tag
des Ehrenamts und das war's von uns
weiter geht's gleich mit dem montagskino
und um Mitternacht meldet sich
Christopher wermann mit unserem heute
journal Update bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend da kommt ein neues
tieferan und das bringt deutlich mildere
Temperaturen mit und wenn jetzt also
Regen auf den en Boden fällt dann wird
es spiegelglatt aber es kommt nicht nur
Regen es kommt auch Schnee heran und
zwar hier in Norddeutschland da können
innerhalb von 12 Stunden bis morgen früh
durchaus 5 cm Neuschnee fallallen
gefährlich aber ist eindeutig der
Glatteisregen und mit diesem Eisregen
sollten Sie heute Nacht in Teilen von
nordrin-westfalen rheinlandpalz hessen-
Thüringen badenwürttenberg und Bayern
rechnen über den Schneeflächen in Bayern
sinken die Temperaturen bis -8° aber von
Westen wird's milder und so liegen die
Temperaturen an der sadan bei + 4° und
morgen zieht dieses Tief weiter
nordwärts und vertreibt die Schneewolken
zur Ostsee dann kommen neue Schnee und
Regenfälle im Südwesten auf
Schneefallgrenze dann so 400 bis 600 m
es gibt morgen aber auch einen ganz
freundlichen Bereich hier zwischen dem
Thüringerwald dem Odenwald und der Donau
die Temperaturen steigen auf -2° im
nördlichen Brandenburg und bis + 7° am
oberrein am Mittwoch ändert sich noch
nicht so viel der Donnerstag wird dann
deutlich freundlicher und am Freitag
kommen neue Schnee und Regenwolken von
Westen heran und vielleicht fragen Sie
sich ja wie viel von dem Schnee der
jetzt aktuell liegt und das ist ja
wirklich ganz verbreitet und zwar heftig
weiß in Deutschland bleibt denn wohl bis
zur nächsten Woche liegen na ja sie
werden sehen vor allen Dingen in den
Mittelgebirgen und in Süddeutschland
werden sich die Schneewolken die
Schneeflächen wohl behaupten können
guten Abend